this is the southern appalachian  salamander  it breathes entirely through its skin  which makes it incredibly sensitive to  water quality and temperature  and with average temperatures increasing  yearly their future has become quite  murky  the appalachian region is home to more  salamander species than anywhere else in  the world  adults top out at 7 inches and females  are slightly larger than males  they are found across the carolinas  georgia and tennessee  they live in wet forested areas as they  need to stay moist to respirate properly  unfortunately these areas have been  shrinking and warming up quickly climate  change and habitat loss are grave  concerns for this remarkable species  this is the southern appalachian  salamander  you